yeah your mom okay what you say what you
write it's my baby boy my son
[Laughter]
wow
wow this is beautiful
you haven't seen this one before
this is great thanks Ron you're welcome
that's great wow
hey yo um
you took this picture oh no that was
taken before I came here
who took this picture you know you want
to open up mine next
yeah
where do I start
oh see I think I know what this is let's
see
oh wow yo these are the limited limited
editions oh
thank you oh my God
how much do signs you wouldn't cost
these days but I swear I didn't know
that she was filled pop was so expensive
just couldn't let me have this moment
could you
please do not make this about our issues
will is happy
happy hours Let's drop it
disrespect me in front of my child
I just don't understand you
how you got like this like what being
successful because that's what you're
mad about because more of my dreams came
true so now you gotta cut me down
whenever you get a chance girl your
dreams came true because Mama supported
you
because I supported you and then Phil
supported you you didn't climb no
mountain
you were carried and what I gave to you
and now to will it ain't flashy or
dramatic enough to be remembered or even
given credit for
but you kind of fixed in your mind that
that's what I am
you know what's clear
what's clear is the before before this
fancy house I was the one who helped you
find your voice as an artist when you
needed materials I bought them for you I
had to move to L.A and I paid your bills
and the second you didn't need me you
just you erased me you erased me from
your life
you want my son to do the same thing
[Music]
look
um after seeing our moms today I can
honestly say I have no intention of
having a decades-long grudge with you
all
me either but I don't know how we can
move forward if you can't accept the
fact that I'm with Lisa now
all right um
this isn't just about Lisa all right you
coming here sent me into a spiral I was
already having a rough time at school
getting good grades and leading my
lacrosse team to state championships and
my parents needed me to be basically
[__] perfect all right it's
exhausting
and you just show up and hook up with my
ex
so me being what Lisa is the straw that
broke the camel's back exactly
he just strolled up in here and my
parents loved you the girls at school
pretty much couldn't get enough of you
and it's like everything that I had to
work really hard for you just had
without even trying
I hear you so basically what you're
saying is
you're a hater
yeah yeah I'm playing I am joking
I feel you I get you sort of
but I guess I mean my only question is
moving forward
do you still have a problem with me
being with Lisa because I can't be
looking over my shoulder every five
seconds bro
I mean
look I'm
honestly
it hurts but me and Lisa are over we
have been for a while and
and who she dates next is none of my
business
promise me you won't hurt her okay
she got enough of that for me
you have my word
[Music]
foreign